hello this is the Sky News special
program financial crisis explained an
hour of insight and analysis on the
turmoil affecting the pound coming up
No Going Back the Prime Minister defends
her mini budget and rules out a U-turn
despite growing political and economic
pressure
it was the right decision to take
and we need to continue to make sure we
deliver the economic growth we deliver
the jobs and opportunities
concerns over an emergency interest rate
hike haven't gone away lenders have
withdrawn a further 321 mortgage
products today
a 65 billion pound intervention by the
bank of England saved many Pension funds
and brought calm to the markets
yesterday but will that last
well over the next hour our top business
team are here I'm joined by our city
editor Mark Kleinman our business
presenter Ian King and our economics and
data editor Ed Conway
[Music]
before all of that we start with some
breaking news we've just heard from the
Prime Minister Liz truss on the pressure
facing the pound
I think we have to look at what
situation this country would be in if we
hadn't acted people were facing fuel
bills energy bills of up to six thousand
pounds we had very high inflation
expectations and an economic slowdown
and what we've done is we've taken
decisive action first of all to make
sure that nobody is paying more than a
typical fuel bill of two thousand five
hundred pounds that will come in this
Saturday but also to reduce our tax
burden to make sure we grow the economy
and also curb inflation and that's so
important it's a difficult time we're
facing a global economic crisis brought
about by Putin's war in Ukraine and what
was right is that Britain took decisive
action to help people get through what
is going to be a difficult winter it's
incredible to suggest that the mini
Budget on Friday didn't have an impact
on what has happened over the last few
days are you really suggesting that well
the biggest measure in the mini budget
was the support we have given to people
on their energy bills and it was
absolutely right that we gave that
support because without that support
people would be facing High fuel bills
this winter I was worried about people
struggling to eat their homes but also
we but also also we would have seen
businesses like pubs go out of business
so the it was the right decision to take
and we need to continue to make sure we
deliver the economic growth that we
deliver the jobs and opportunities and
that is the long-term future that we
have set out just on delivery then um
we're being told already that government
departments are looking for efficiencies
they're being told to look for
efficiencies where on Earth are those
efficiencies going to come from it's
absolutely right that we always need to
get value for taxpayers money you know
every pound that we take from somebody
is a pound they could be spending doing
on their you know future on there you
know what they need to support
themselves so it's right that we get
value for money and I'm always making
sure that we deliver that we're from
well there are always ways that we can
organize things more efficiently but
what I want to make sure is taxpayer
money is focused on Frontline services
on getting our GP appointments making
sure people can get to see a doctor
making sure we deliver on our road
projects all of those things that people
rely on us for but there are plenty of
areas where the government can become
more efficient
well not not at the moment we're
continually reviewing to make sure we're
getting good value for money and I think
that's what taxpayers expect
let's trust there well over the next
hour we'll be dissecting the
government's economic plans and asking
what went wrong on the markets we have
our city editor Mark Kleinman our
business presenter Ian King and our
economics and data editor Ed Conway here
but first let's take a look back at a
week or even just a few days that few
could have predicted Bill started last
Friday at 9 30 in the morning we saw the
chancellor quasi-quartang announced his
mini budget revealing a major tax
cutting plan as part of his new agenda
for growth
pounds slumped almost immediately and
had plunged to its lowest level in 37
years by around three o'clock that
afternoon
on Monday the pound hit an all-time low
against the dollar down to one dollar
and three cents
late on Tuesday night the lender of Last
Resort the international monetary fund
took the rare decision to urge the
government to re-evaluate its tax cut
plan warning it would Stoke Rising
inflation and increase inequality
and then yesterday that major moment
when we saw the bank of England step in
launching a huge 65 billion pound
intervention
stop a run on pensions funds
let's start by bringing in our economics
and data editor at Conway and it has
been quite a week that's for sure what's
the current state of play with the pound
and on the markets so yeah let's start
by I'll do a bit of an update and I've
got some charts that I can show you just
kind of the story of the past week but
also you know some of the bigger picture
uh events let's start by looking uh at
the pound uh I'll bring that up because
I mean you know a lot of at least the
focus has been about Sterling uh and
particularly Sterling against the dollar
now there's loads of things that go on
when it comes to financial markets so
you can't just attribute this to one
single thing but let's just look at that
picture the higher this line is the
stronger the pound is against the dollar
and this is obviously last week Thursday
Bank of England meeting around there uh
Friday that was the moment of the mini
budget I mean whatever you want to call
it mini budget budget but look at what
happens pound afterwards really a very
big four on an intraday basis an
unusually big fall uh for the pound and
then over the weekend we heard more from
quasi quattang saying that they were
going to be more unfunded tax cuts
potentially and look at what happened to
this dark blue line after that when
markets opened look it went down even
further and then gradually started to
recover over the course of the day on
Monday you know this is we're really
just looking back at the last week or so
then came statements from the treasury
and for the bank of England The Hope was
that was going to calm markets but look
what happened to the pound afterwards
actually went down a little bit until
through into Wednesday when we had that
bank of England intervention now here's
the interesting thing a lot of people
wondering whether the bank still had the
kind of Firepower and credibility to
move markets well certainly that did
happen the currency was not obviously
not the thing they were focusing on they
were focusing on Government Bond markets
but even so look at what happened
afterwards the pound rallied a touch and
today actually it is relatively stable
certainly in comparison with previous
days it is it is doing okay and actually
those Bond markets looking relatively
stable in comparison with before the
other thing uh have I got time for one
more chance to do that okay right the
other thing um is looking at what's
happening with interest rates because I
think you know in a sense this is part
of the big story but this is just
showing you so rather than just looking
back at the last few days this is
showing you over recent history so going
all the way back to the 1960s the level
of interest rates and I think what I
want to do here in particular is just
provide some context for whether the
fact that we're very low at the moment
is something we can be incredibly
reassured by or not because a lot of
people will have said look interest
rates are incredibly high back in the
80s back in the 70s so isn't this
actually you know a bit of fuss about
nothing well here's what here's the
thing you need to adjust for the fact
that around now we tend to have higher
debt levels than we did back then also
our incomes in comparison to those
repayments are a bit lower so when you
adjust for all of that stuff you get a
slightly different picture this line
here this red line here is adjusted for
that kind of affordability levels and
what you can probably make out is while
in actually I'll highlight one bit here
so you can actually kind of see what's
going on here by the way that's the
expectation uh for the coming uh months
the expectation is that rates are going
to get up to about six percent next year
so that line kind of dotted line goes a
bit higher but as I say even so that
doesn't look terrifyingly high compared
with what we see here until you focus on
the fact that really it's the red line
you need to be looking at to get a
historical comparison and that red line
shows you that back in the 1980s it is
true headline interest rates are about
14 or so but actually when you adjust
for the fact that a lot of people had
lower levels of debt by then those
mortgages even with high interest rates
were more affordable it's equivalent to
about three percent in today's money so
that's the key thing although 1980s
interest rates were certainly a lot
higher in headline terms in practice
when it comes to repaying them they were
considerably lower and if we focus just
on this red line which is kind of the
one that matters at the moment and look
at where it's heading up to at the
moment how high is that in historical
comparison draw that back about 6.1 by
the way I just looked at markets they're
expecting 6.1 interest rates or so next
year that's the highest level that we
seen since around there the end of the
1980s early 90s and that of course
precipitated an enormous housing bust so
really that's the thing that's changed
you know I think this past week or so
what's changed is that we
previously we're looking at interest
rates going up to maybe kind of four
percent four point seven five percent
which is already pretty high now those
expectations even though the pound has
recovered a still that we're going to
have very high interest rates next year
and you know to to a degree that we
hadn't really seen for a long time okay
we're going to talk a lot about interest
rates uh in in the next little section
of the program but let's for now I think
just focus on what's happened over the
last 48 hours because I think people are
still pretty much reeling and Mark when
when we saw the way that the markets
reacted
why do why do you think they reacted the
way they did well markets have been
grappling with the economic Outlook and
the path forward for unwinding many of
the financial crisis era measures that
were taken when the banking crisis was
in a state of complete meltdown you know
13 or 14 years ago we've had a period of
historically low uh interest rates since
then and so there's a sense uh in the
city that the levers that the bank of
England has still got to pull are now
very limited there are a number of other
major concerns as well one of them is
that under Liz truss's Administration
there is a very real sense that the
treasury and the bank of England are
working at Cross purposes and that is a
major concern in financial markets and
particularly for international investors
in sovereign debt in UK sovereign debt
so you've got that tension uh there I'll
just pointed there because I had
somebody on the radio this morning
describe it as the government
being in a car and having the foot on
the accelerator and the treasury having
their foot on the brake and it's the
back of that tension yes the bank of
England with his foot on the break
absolutely it's a it's a good metaphor
for the situation that we're in at the
moment fiscal and monetary policy
um working almost in in opposition and
you're going to stop you again what's
the difference between because a lot of
people don't understand it what's the
difference between fiscal policy and
monetary policy so fiscal policy is is
around government measures to stimulate
the economy and monetary policies set by
the bank of England uh MPC the uh
covering interest rates of course and
the uh other big issue now is that we
have a a crisis in liquidity that we've
seen affecting Pension funds which is
why the bank of England had to step in
yesterday with this uh 65 billion pounds
uh and very rare intervention
um that may need to be extended
according to many of the people I'm
talking to in financial markets that
um yes as Ed pointed out out there's
some stability was restored yesterday
some order was restored and that has to
be a positive thing but this is a
program that will come to an end in a
couple of weeks time and many of the
Pension funds uh whose uh you know
retirement savings are invested in and
that affect millions of people around
the country they are concerned that some
of the collateral calls either the
demands that they have from their
investment managers to post money to
meet the changes that we've seen in
guilt prices and so on
um are not going to be sufficient when
this Bank of England program runs out
okay there's lots of words there lots of
people might still not understand Ian um
I'm going to get you to try and explain
it for us just explain to some really
simple terms if you can exactly what
happened yesterday in in term I think
people understand that that there are
pensions that a lot of people invest in
and it might be a Company pension or it
might be a personal pension and and
they're invested in different things
that you don't really understand and
know a great deal about uh what was it
that the bank actually did yesterday why
what was the wobble about pensions in
particular well this was a very specific
intervention made by the bank of England
uh what in the jargon is the long end of
the guilt yield curve now these are the
ones for a long period of time guilt the
UK government bonds ious every uh
government issues them it's the main way
in which the government finances its
day-to-day spending other than raising
taxation you will rate you will borrow
money and you'll raise uh raise it by
selling guilds to investors and
typically they are long-term investors
financial institutions Pension funds and
so forth and this issue was specifically
around the 20 to 30 year guilds and why
why did it flow up there well basically
if you're a pension fund the natural
buyers for these sort of assets are
Pension funds because if you're a
pension fund manager you want to know
your your liabilities are a long way out
in the future your payments to Future
retirees so you want a guaranteed income
stream that you can meet those demands
in years to come so you would typically
buy 20 to 30 year girls because you know
the money is going to come in because
the government issues when it issues
guilts is sales skills it uh
but there are regular coupons that come
with it which are basically interest
payments from the government so if
you're a pension fund manager that's a
nice safe investment particularly with
the UK government with its sort of AAA
credit rating so it's a very very safe
non-risky investment but what's been
happening is that these Pension funds
also take out insurance in case they're
suddenly caught out by inflation by
sudden moves and interest rates and
that's what's been going on the
counterparties on the other sides of
those trades because of these sharp
Falls have said well we need you to put
up more collateral you pension funds we
need you to put up more more money so
the fund managers that sit in the middle
of all this the likes of legal in
general have been turning around to the
Pension funds and saying we need you to
put up more cash in collateral and the
easiest way to do that if your pension
fund is to sell your long guilds because
they're a big liquid Market the price
accordingly uh felt pretty sharply
particularly on Monday morning there
were reports that legal in general for
example were asking for billions of
pounds from these Pension funds over the
weekends that's why you saw the prices
come off and potentially that raises all
sorts of concerns about the value of the
assets that these funds are sitting on
and that's why the bank intervened in
the way it did and it's actually it's a
very very specific intervention at the
long end these very specific things and
and then what would happen if what would
have happened if the bank hadn't
intervened how catastrophic could it
have been because it was a surprise that
they intervened and you were explaining
yesterday what it was all about we were
all sort of like scratching our heads
going what why have they done I'm still
scratching my head about it you know
it's explained it better than anyone
I've heard there because you know this
is a complex part of the the market I
mean the big picture is the bank does
not intervene unless there is a serious
risk of deep financial trouble and
that's that doesn't necessarily just
mean the pension system it means the
broader guilts Market you know it's
looking working out whether there's
going to be any kind of systemic risk
what they mean by systemic risk a
problem that seems relatively small to
start off with although this Market
we're talking about was you know
trillion and a half pounds worth
potentially and then can Cascade into a
serious financial crisis that means all
sorts of other parts of the market are
facing trouble so that's the first thing
to bear in mind they do not take these
kind of decisions lightly they do them
very rarely indeed the last time they
did anything similar was maybe covid in
the financial crisis as well
um and so if they hadn't intervened
first of all there was the risk of
potential Mass defaults in many of these
instruments there was the risk of deeper
problems what they call you know as Ian
was saying kind of along the curve so
you have other parts of the financial
system which rely on these bonds and
what what we're talking about here is
the plumbing for the UK economic system
guilts bonds they're basically pretty
boring and they're boring most of the
time and they're supposed to be boring
because this is the boring part of the
market where people making long-term
decisions with all of our money and they
put allocate them in certain places and
guilts play a crucial role though it's a
foundation stone for everything else so
when that foundation stone is shaking
and over the course of the last week it
has been shaking because of the massive
movements we've seen in those in those
Securities which are in part a
consequence of people saying oh hang on
the UK is going to be borrowing a lot
more money you know it's back to last
Friday the UK is going to be borrowing a
lot more money how do we adjust to that
and it's sending this kind of chain
reaction through those markets where
unexpected things are happening and one
of those unexpected things that happened
is it turns out there's a big part of
the pensions Market where they're
reliant on certain Securities certain
derivatives and you get a bit of a kind
of spiral so the bank detected that a
lot of people kind of talking to people
in the city saying and then the bank
listening to that saying they would need
to kind of step in and do something
about it as as Mark and Ian was saying
the interesting and I think significant
thing here and a cause for you know
reassurance is there was a period you
know during this week where people were
a bit worried that even if the bank did
do something that it wouldn't
necessarily have the impact that they
had hoped for so the merest fact that we
have seen you saw it there the pound
coming back quite a bit guilts yields
coming down quite a bit that is quite
reassuring it shows they still have
power but they've had to kind of get out
of bazooka to reassure people and the
facts you know we'll still will come to
this the political Edge to this is
they've had to do this largely in
response I mean the government doesn't
acknowledge this but pretty much
everyone else they talk out and talk at
all in markets will say this they've had
to do it in response to what the
government has done last week this has
been the bank of England at its best
though as said said there were a lot of
doubts that the bank would be able to
take any action here you know you've had
people on John Redwood telling Kay
Burley earlier this week it's not the
bank's job to defend Sterling well the
bank has made a big meaningful
intervention as that said it picked up
very very quickly on these pressures
that were building up in the markets I
think the bank of England comes out of
this episode looking pretty good to be
honest and that's significant given that
the monetary policy committee is under a
lot of fire for being behind the curve
on inflation and not raising interest
rates rapidly enough that is true but
the question remains that if this
program has to be extended after two
weeks does the bank retain does the bank
retain that credibility and that's an
open question and do you feel Mark you
know as Ed was saying that um when we
look at what happened what's happened in
the market there the last 48 hours that
the bank's actions have now calmed
things that it does feel that everything
is just kind of everyone's drawing
breath again yeah I think that there's
certainly been that temporary pause for
breath that was the obviously the
objects the objects of the exercise
um but that's not to say that this is a
a line in the sand that uh that means
that stability will endure beyond the
end of this this two-week intervention
by the bank of England I think a lot of
the question marks still remain about
the government's response to this crisis
whether the government even acknowledges
that there is a crisis in financial
markets at the moment I spoke to one
former treasury Minister uh this morning
who uh insists that his intelligence
from his contacts in uh within
government is that there is no crisis
that the treasury that the chancellor is
not
acknowledging that there is a real
crisis in financial markets at the
moment and one of the things we've seen
since Liz truss came to power and
appointed quasi-quarting as her
Chancellor is that the treasury which is
the most important Department of State
in many respects is has been hollowed
out in terms of its leadership the first
one of the first actions that the
chancellor took was to sack the
long-serving permanent secretary the top
civil servant Tom scholar you know some
somebody who commands respect from
across the political spectrum they they
and but does that seem to be have been a
political decision uh very much so
there's a there's a a long-standing
criticism from uh from Mr quote and and
from Liz truss about treasury Orthodoxy
and about the way the treasury
approaches uh financial markets and
economic uh policy and Tom scholar paid
paid the price for that the problem is
nobody's been appointed in his place
there is also another layer underneath
uh Mr scholar which is uh vacant at the
moment the second permanent secretary
another very very senior uh job and if
you look at the ministerial lineup in
the treasury at the moment there are
five treasury ministers only one of them
has had any previous experience of
working in the treasury and and that was
only for a few short weeks during that
period before Boris Johnson stepped down
so there is a real real there appears to
be a real vacuum of leadership in the
treasury at the moment and given what's
going on in terms of government policy
around the the vast energy bailout
package that's been unveiled in the last
couple of uh weeks and all of the other
Associated economic challenges around
the inflationary pressures that the
economy is facing
um this is not really the right time for
there to be a vacuum of leadership at
the treasury just to back that up you
know I've I've also had a few
conversations and it is quite startling
and Stark the way that you know number
10 genuinely does believe that what's
happening now the instability is not a
consequence of what they did on Friday
they say it just doesn't add up it
doesn't compute and they do they claim
that it is you know this is this is
other things it's Noises Off
but that is for a lot for most Market
participants that I've spoken to that's
kind of Staggering because you know your
first step in addressing some of the
instability we're seeing at the moment
is kind of acknowledging that there is
something that needs to be done whether
it's more explaining about the plan uh
or whether it's a change of plan and
this is not really a partisan thing you
know that this is millions of people out
there making decisions about what to do
with their money and looking at the UK
and saying well do we want to put it in
there I'm not sure about that it's not
partisan it's not about left or right
it's about credibility and it's about
faith in the system and regaining that
faith is very difficult but part of the
job is actually kind of saying okay
we're gonna we're gonna kind of
collaborate and work out what to do next
okay if you're just joining us a
reminder you're watching a special Sky
News program financial crisis explained
we're talking to three of our top
business experts and trying to help you
understand helping me understand what's
causing the volatility in the markets
we've got our city editor Mark Kleinman
our business presenter Ian King and our
economics and data editor Ed Conway here
let's just go back to Monday at a fairly
ominous quote from the bank of England
Governor Andrew Bailey in response to
the pound plummeting he said the
monetary policy committee will not
hesitate to change interest rates by as
much as needed to return inflation to
its two percent Target as much as needed
um Mark how high do some people fear
interest rates could go well I think as
Ed was showing on his earlier chart
there's a sort of Baseline assumption
now they could go to six percent or or
more over the next year or two
um
who knows at the moment who knows we're
in a period of uh of genuine economic
uncertainty uh with the uh inflationary
pressures that are affecting the economy
and have been for many months since
indeed the bank of England started to
raise uh the base rate
um it really is unclear how high
interest rates might go and of course
that has implications for our viewers
and all of us in in almost every area of
our financial lives
just to back that up show us some charts
and then I'll just be the chart monkey a
bit but I won't I won't kind of
necessarily go up here
um so you should have someone before
that showed how high it could go and the
difference between exactly that a bit of
historical comparison but just kind of
to get a sense of exactly what Mark was
saying
um a bit of now expectations previously
where interest rates might head I don't
know let's bring them up here if we can
and then perhaps I'll stay here and show
you
um so this basically is where rates have
been in the past so you see the straight
line the the non-dotted line and that is
where interest rates have gone okay but
the dotted line is kind of expectations
for people in the market about where
they thought they were going to go and
back in February look that dotted line
was only going to Peak at about one and
a half percent okay so all this is doing
is giving you a sense of how the
expectations have changed this is
looking into the Future Okay so this is
your not necessarily your mortgage rate
but you can imagine your mortgage rate
is that plus a bit on top of it
um then by August look at what happened
to that line now this is people starting
to realize hey there's lots of inflation
B There is a war in Ukraine and C as
well we have a new government
potentially coming in and they have new
plans uh with the public finances but we
didn't know at that stage who was
necessarily going to win although
Napoleon was pointing towards Linda's
trust then by the time Liz trust was in
office look at what's happened to that
line it's going even higher so the
expectation at that point was no it's
not going to be one and a half percent
next year it's not going to be two in a
bit it's going to be 4.75 that was
already looking pretty painful but now
look what's happened after the mini
budget okay so look at that line again
future interest rate expectations and
look at how it's gone up to as Mike was
saying up to these kind of levels of six
percent it's a little bit above six
percent uh today and that's the point
you know this no one knows for sure
what's going to happen all this is is
kind of a measure of what people within
money markets are kind of placing bets
on for this future of interest rates but
that is what feeds into our mortgages
right now because people have to make
decisions uh investors and mortgage
lenders how to make decisions based on
what money markets are saying what money
Market's the same right now as interest
rates are going to be a lot higher next
year than anyone previous obviously
thought and those kinds of shifts I mean
you know Ian might have a feeling about
this that's that's pretty unusual isn't
it yeah it's a very very spectacular
increase you just don't see movements
like that in the in expectations as
dramatic as that nor indeed in the way
that guilt yields have been moving over
the last uh five days since the mini
budget as well I mean these as Ed was
saying guilts are supposed to be really
dull safe Investments you just don't see
yields spiking like that you really
don't I mean it's you've seen girls
behaving like sort of text docs or
something like that and we're not
expecting another interest rate rise uh
until November but do you think there's
a possibility that that one could come
sooner than that well the the best guess
that we have on that comes from the
comments that you pill the chief
Economist at the bank of England made
the day before yesterday where he was
very very clear that he didn't want the
NPC to be moving until the 3rd of
November which is when its next policy
decision is due who knows if you get
more turmoil in in markets of the kind
that we've seen this week and this is
the thing that this is kind of the
experience that we've seen in previous
Financial crises we get days like this
when things calm down and then all of a
sudden you'll get another Lurch lower in
the price of an asset and Away you go
again so it's too soon I think to say
that uh that we're out of the woods in
terms of this stuff and Sterling is
indeed drifting on the Forex markets uh
right now again so Sterling is yet
foreign exchange yeah sorry
um
so events May Force the NPC's hand to
move but I mean they're very clear that
they don't want to go before the third
of November but if the markets force
their hand they may well have to I mean
October is going to be a really really
choppy and uncertain month because we've
got two things that we're expecting to
happen not until November one is the MPC
meeting on the 3rd of November the other
is the medium-term strategy that
quasi-karting is promising us that's not
until the 23rd of November and financial
markets like nature report a vacuum you
know they rely on information they rely
on on supposition and gossip and
speculation and if you don't get the
authorities saying anything for five
weeks well as I say we could be in for a
really choppy October and Marco if rates
do go up again before November what
impact will that have on the markets do
you think well I mean it's uh it is
clear that there is a chance that there
will be an emergency rate hike one gets
the sense that Andrew Bailey the
governor of the bank of England is doing
everything he can avoid that possibility
it would be truly disastrous if the bank
of England were to announce an emergency
rate hike and and not achieve the
desired effect I mean clearly uh given
what Ian was just saying about the delay
until the next uh set of fiscal
projections and how the government
intends to pay for these uh 45 billion
pounds of tax cuts that were announced
in the mini budget last week it doesn't
feel right now that that delay until the
back half of November is sustainable it
doesn't feel tenable given the level of
uncertainty uh the level of volatility
in financial markets I mean before that
statement towards the end of November
quasi-quarting is due to be presenting a
package of deregulatory measures
relating to the city something that's
being nicknamed Big Bang 2.0 that's
something that we saw a taster of in his
statement last week the the abolition of
the capital Bankers bonuses the
abolition of the top rate of income tax
and the other Associated uh tax cuts
that he unveiled initially to Euphoria
in the city as to be said largely
because many of the Traders and and
other senior City Executives will be the
beneficiaries of those of those tax cuts
but it feels now questionable as to
whether that big bang 2.0 package can
come before uh this uh scheduled
statement towards the end of November
because as Ian says markets really
dislike the idea of a vacuum unless the
Traders unless Traders are benefiting
from the volatility associated with it
okay well well we're thinking about
what's happening in the Traders at
personal Pockets but as we've been
hearing these are all major impacts that
can have on all of our personal finances
and there are experts here are ready to
take your questions at home coming up at
half past one we're going to have a
special q a with this Motley panel scan
the QR code on your screen right now and
put your questions about the crisis to
add Mark and Ian so if you've got
questions about the financial crisis
about is there something you don't
understand or is it something that you
want to know personally about how it
could affect you we'll try and answer it
at 1 30 so get your questions in to us
you are watching a special Sky News
program financial crisis explained
coming up in the second half of the
program we're going to be looking at how
to fix the crisis on the market and
discuss potential Solutions
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the special skynees
program financial crisis explained where
we're talking to three of our top
business experts about the pressure on
the pound our city editor Mark Kleinman
our business presenter Ian King and our
economics and data editor at Conway are
still all here we're going to try to
discuss some solutions to the current
crisis the biggest one that we've seen
so far was of course the bank of
England's intervention yesterday to buy
65 billion pounds worth of bonds to
prevent a major crisis within Britain's
pensions schemes
well is that intervention working Ed's
Conway let's bring you in I mean it does
seem that the markets have calmed since
then this is you know this particular
intervention seems to have done the
trick in the short term but but what
about the longer term a lot of people
are saying scrap that mini budget from
Friday would that actually make a
difference now I mean it's hard to tell
in as much as you know you can't
absolutely put your finger on one
particular thing whether it's a policy
or a move that was the explanation you
know there's a load of different things
and it means that in the same way as it
becomes very difficult to diagnose
exactly how this happened it becomes
quite difficult to diagnose you know
what are the buttons you could press
um clearly acknowledging that there's an
issue might be a star I mean before we
even get to kind of you know policy
prescriptions and and what to do next
the fact that the government at the
moment believes this is an entirely
International Financial Market stability
issue rather than something that's kind
of domestic
that I think is unnerving people because
it's like well let's start with the
acceptance form of part of grief before
we kind of deal with the rest of it but
I mean it's hard to say some people
think you know and I was talking to
Charlie being a former bank of England
Deputy Governor and he he thinks either
either you do a U-turn or
um you're kind of basically okay with
the bank of England raising the rates to
these kind of levels that are incredibly
high and you just have to take that on
the chin although that's going to mean
possibly a recession certainly very very
tough times next year and the run-up or
you have to unveil a set of spending
cuts and fiscal discipline fiscal
discipline basically bringing all of
that borrowing under control or
providing kind of some detail on how
you're going to bring it back but the
scale of those spending cuts would be
enormous because the scale of the extra
borrowing is enormous as well and the
difficulty here is we are trapped in a
kind of a vicious cycle going down in
the wrong direction the government
wanted us to have a kind of virtuous
cycle so generate extra growth from all
of these Supply reforms and there's a
lot to be said about some of the reforms
in in the package and that generates
extra growth That Pie gets bigger
everyone gets richer the scale of your
debts are kind of lower because you know
they're measured compared with your
ability to pay them so it's like you
know all of us households around the
country we earn more therefore our
mortgage seems less expensive by by the
month
instead though of being in that kind of
virtuous circle where things are getting
better we're trapped in this other one
where things are getting worse and the
problem is that that then means that all
of the things that might just have been
affordable on last Friday suddenly
actually don't look affordable you know
the debt interest bill because of all
these charts we've been showing you
about interest rates going up well
they're going up potentially for us as
consumers but they're going up for the
government as well that means you've got
an extra 20 billion maybe of of debt
interest a loan that you need to pay for
I mean that's kind of a small government
department on top of everything else and
that's leaving aside all of the extra
measures that you've got so the issue
Jane I think is that there is no easy
button to press and there is no
businesses buttons press because we are
trapped in what is the fact of their
kind of credibility crisis a lot of
people Market investors out there
non-partisan at partisan as I'm saying
so you know they're not just kind of
doing this on an ideological basis are
really skeptical about this government's
ability and its plan and you need a
pretty dramatic kind of a acknowledgment
acceptance change of plan or indeed kind
of detail on plan to get things through
and right now the fact that we're not
hearing much from the PM and the
chancellor is an issue on that front and
Ian Ed was talking about that global
economic issues and that is something
the government have been saying we heard
them this morning arguing again that
this is a global issue the you know the
bank in Japan had to step in to help the
Yen against the dollar is that
comparable
um well Japan is a very very weird uh
economy full stop I mean it's the most
indebted Rich Nation on Earth but the
benefit for Japan is that most of its
government debt is owned by Japanese
people and Japanese institutions whereas
the UK and the famous words of Mark
Carney the former bank of England
Governor we are dependent on the
kindness of strangers but there it's
fair to say that I mean inflation has
taken hold everywhere you've seen
central banks raising interest rates
left right and center the Federal
Reserve two weeks ago raised by three
quarters of one percent for the third
month running even the European Central
Bank has raised interest rates by
three-quarters one percent in its last
meeting the Bank of Canada Reserve Bank
of Australia Reserve Bank in New Zealand
all of them are hiking rates and at the
same time we are seeing some
extraordinary moves on currency markets
the the pound is not the only currency
that's hit an all-time low against the
dollar recently so is the Indian rupee
for example the Yen's at a 24 year low
the Euros at a 20-year low so there's a
lot of dollar strength in this but there
are you unique Sterling weakness points
to make as well because the IMF have an
issued warnings to those countries well
the IMs intervention is really
interesting I mean it's very very rare
for the IMF to criticize a G7 economy
really right I I interviewed Mohammed
alerian uh yesterday he's one of the
four most commentators on on these sort
of things and he he was making the point
that he thought that the IMF were
basically shown that they had to be
even-handed because quite often the IMF
only beats up on emerging market
economies and he thinks that they were
trying to show a bit more
even-handedness in uh in saying that as
well just to pick up on something that
Ed said about canceling the mini budget
I don't think that's a that's a
non-starter for the very simple reason
if you think about what was in the mini
budget the biggest single item the
biggest ticket item is the energy price
guarantee and for that reason alone I
think they have to get that through on
on the finance bill otherwise households
and businesses are not going to be
insulated from these higher energy
prices this winter and politically the
idea of
rowing back on uh the the chancellors
and and this administration's first
major uh fiscal intervention just
doesn't seem uh politically tenable it
it seems like something much more
dramatic would have to happen in
financial markets to even uh for for Liz
truss and her cabinet to even
contemplate uh such an idea it just does
not seem like it's on the cards we heard
her speaking earlier today when she
talked about the need to press ahead
with these reforms and as Ed was
pointing out there was a a lot on the
supply side that was welcomed last
Friday in the mini budget the problem
was was that one of the major problems
with it was that it was completely
uncosted the office for Budget
responsibility uh was not asked to
provide its own independent forecasts
and as a result of that that fueled the
uncertainty in financial markets about
exactly how these types of tax cuts were
going to be uh were going to be paid for
but but ditching all of those measures
or even any of them any of the more
significant ones that were announced
along last week seems
untenable right now one senior former
treasury official that I spoke to about
an hour ago suggested that there's a
possibility that they could be some of
the measures could be deferred for a
year but again politically you know with
a an Administration that has just a
couple of years left before a general
election it just doesn't seem very
likely and the the the sense in the city
the very pervasive senses that the
government is going to press on with
this package of measures that was
announced last week okay so it doesn't
look like the mini budget is going to be
reversed what then add other tools do we
have what economic tools are there
that the government has that the bank of
England has well I mean so the bank will
always just be watching the markets and
looking at kind of the the broader macro
economy
if something I mean the fact that this
intervention was successful you were
talking about kind of Virtues or Vicious
Cycles the fact that this intervention
they did yesterday was uh uh successful
in the improved interest rates Market it
moved the kind of governmental Market
that means at least there is a little
bit more confidence that the bank can
actually kind of move things if it
wanted to which you know in a strange
way means it might not have to you know
it can actually just because there's a
bit more confidence in it be reassured
that market is going to kind of function
again albeit as Mark was saying with the
fact that they are pumping billions of
pounds of cash in there on a daily basis
and that it's only it's kind of two-week
operation so no one's quite sure what
happens at the end of that
um like I say there's no straightforward
kind of button that you can press I mean
there's in a sense there's there's two
issues here it's not like the UK economy
has just you know become a worse place
overnight there's fundamentals in this
in this country in this kind of level of
dynamism and the companies that there
are
um that are that are strong and this is
is you know still a very healthy economy
fundamentally the issue is just that
there is a crisis of confidence in some
of the institutions that that we used to
rely on to provide the kind of
confidence that people had and that's
you know whether it's the obr whether
it's the treasury whether it's the bank
of England it might be that we're
learning what happens when you spend
years as this government and kind of
previous governments have done
essentially castigating those
institutions and saying we don't pay any
attention to experts
the problem with that though you know as
a kind of diagnosis is okay maybe that
is true what do you do about it you know
and and the answer is you need to build
back trust but building back trust takes
usually many years and in the case of
you know think back to something like
black Wednesday the last kind of serious
really kind of domestic UK financial
crisis that that was something that
obviously damaged the conservatives
reputation for economic credibility for
quite a long time but as well as that it
took quite a long time to rebuild both
the physical position and the state of
the economy what's worrying to me about
this one is
in some senses you know a lot of us look
back at black Wednesday and say that was
one of the best things that ever
happened to the UK economy it was
obviously a terrible financial crisis at
the time horribly High interest rates
for many people partly for that but
partly also for other reasons in the
housing market but then what happened is
the UK was kind of liberated from this
exchange rate Peg and was able to have
really quite a positive bounce back for
much of the 90s where they kind of
rebuilt the public finances and led to
this period in 1997 where new labor came
in they had one of the best fiscal
positions to state of the government
finances that any incoming government
has had in in a long long time this time
around
unfortunately you can't call this a
release it's not like we've released
from anything we've released from these
institutions that everyone quite liked
and was reassured by and now we're kind
of left out in the air in the cold and
it's a question of needing to put things
back together again and and Mark is that
that's reflected in the market isn't it
so do you get a sense now that their
Needs Trust needs to be rebuilt
between the markets between the
government between the treasury between
the bank of England even or just between
the markets and the government really no
very much so Jane I mean that's that's a
key uh point that it was making about
the the need to rebuild trust and that
trust has to be felt by investors
um in order to be restored at the moment
as I say because the treasury in the
Bank of England are seen or are
perceived uh not to be working uh in
tandem despite the Chancellor's
protestations over the last few days
that he's speaking to the governor of
the bank of England every day there is a
sense that they are not working uh hand
in hand and when that uh in uh in the
economic policy of the government a
number of very senior Business Leaders
that I've spoken to and financiers over
the last few days
the majority of those people do think
it's going to be very difficult for this
Chancellor as new as he is in his job to
survive this crisis that uh for Market
confidence to be restored there won't
have to be a change of personnel at the
treasury whether that's true or not
we've heard the Prime Minister say that
that is not on the agenda but this is
not political people you're talking to I
imagine absolutely not these are you
know some of the most senior Business
Leaders in in this country uh and and
some of the most senior Bankers uh
people who have their finger on the
pulse of what's going on in financial
markets all the time not just here but
globally and I have to say it's been
surprising to me just how
um dominant that view has been there'll
be those though who will Who will
perhaps look at this under a different
point of view and I spoke to Daniel
gross who used to be at the IMF um now
the director of the center for European
policy European policy yesterday and he
said that he thought that what the bank
of England had done was give in and
panicked and and he said that the bank
of England is now engaged on a slippery
slope and you know I wonder if there are
some who will look at this and say
actually what Liz trust and what quality
cartoon are trying to do here is
something totally different and and the
people that are complaining and the
people that are panicking are those who
are trapped in perhaps an old mindset we
all need to be a little bit more
open-minded about looking at it in a
different way I can see where they're
coming from one that I think you can
make that uh argument I mean if you
think about what happened the coalition
government was elected in 2010 the
markets then we're very very worried
about the deficit and about the UK's
ability to fund its borrowing income
David Cameron Nick Clegg George Osborne
Danny Alexander and embarked on this
period of retrenchment of trying to cut
public spending where they could have a
public spending carried on Rising but it
didn't carry on rising at the same right
and all this that sort of cheese pairing
cutting a billion pounds here a billion
pounds there well it didn't really
deliver productivity improvements it
didn't really deliver GDP growth of the
sort that one would have hoped to have
seen and so then you get to the pandemic
and all of a sudden the government is
flinging billions of pounds at keeping
people in work through the furlough
scheme and other business support
Ventures government borrowing goes up by
billions and billions of pounds and the
markets don't budge interest rates
didn't move guilt yields were barely
changed and that was probably because
the bank of England had restarted QE but
even so so I can kind of understand why
Liz truss and quasi-carto might have
looked at this and thought well
everything that's been tried before just
has generated negligible growth we need
to get back to a trend rate of two and a
half percent of GDP let's give it a try
and what's really taken them back I
think is the fact that the markets have
reacted in the way that they have done
and the longer term story to this Jane
there are these characters in the
markets who we call the bomb Vigilantes
and these are bond market investors who
hold the Feats of governments to the
fire they keep government policy or they
keep governments honest and it emerged
in the late night in the mid-1990s
um when Clinton was trying to bring down
the U.S deficit and his advisor James
Carville at the time said well if I
believed in reincarnation I'd want to
come back as a great baseball player or
something like that he said I've now
decided I want to come back as the bond
markets because they can uh frighten you
into doing anything you want now over
the years the bomb Vigilantes have tried
it with Japan didn't really get anywhere
because as I say Japan's quite annoyed
uh economy in an odd Market they tried
it with the US they tried it with the
Eurozone you know you have the Eurozone
debt crisis where you saw bond yields of
Spanish Greek Italian government debt
blowing out in comes Mario draghi the
president of the ECB and just says we
will do whatever it takes to defend the
Euro and he did and they invested
trillions of Euros in quantitative
easing so Japan too big to take on
Eurozone too big to take on the U.S
certainly big too big to take on the UK
as a as the next biggest sort of G7
economy probably the bomb Vigilantes
might fancy trying to discipline the UK
into a bit of fiscal prudence and I
think that we've had a that's kind of
what we've seen it sounds really
nefarious it sounds like there's a
terrifying group of people who are well
not trying to control it's not the
markets are dispassionate but Market
investors are dispassionate they're
unsentimental they're looking at the at
when chiefly whether a bonding bond
issuer is good for the money whether
they can repay same as the bank manager
is when you come in and ask for a loan
that they're assessing your credit
worthiness and if they decide that
you're crediting worthiness is shot well
they're going to sell your debt and this
is the thing like in the UK they're the
kinds of things that bond from atlantes
get upset about are massive current
account deficits massive fiscal deficits
current account deficit basically means
you'll relying on other people to
provide money to kind of Finance you
um fiscal deficits governments borrowing
loads of money and put those two things
together that's the recipe that they are
kind of looking out for in the UK has
been kind of okay for the past
decades even though it's had both of
those but suddenly you're okay until
you're not and that that's the worry is
maybe we've gone over that edge okay a
reminder at home if you just tuned in
you're watching financial crisis
explained we're joined by three of our
top business experts about the crisis
hitting the markets we've got our city
editor Mark Kleinman our business
presenter Ian King and our economics and
data editor at Conway is still here to
explain the finer details we're now
going to look towards the future uh and
consider what might happen next uh
crystal ball time at the ready
um also I should remind you that a
little bit later we're going to be
giving you an opportunity to put some of
your questions to our experts I'll tell
you a little bit more about that in a
short while but but Ed just in terms of
looking at the future the government
appears to be doubling down
um are we going to see more more Bank of
England interventions do you think
we just have to wait and see I mean like
yesterday would I have guessed that that
was about to happen I mean Ian you
probably had a hunch about it but I you
know I had no idea that the bank were
about to intervene in a way that we
hadn't really kind of seen before so
it's inherently the future is inherently
unpredictable uh in markets like this
you know I've got memories of the last
financial crisis and it was just a case
of some days seemed calm and it was like
oh maybe it's okay maybe we can relax
now and then the next day was miserable
and then the next day after that was
calm and the next day was miserable
we just have to hope that that that's
not the pattern we're going to see now
but it's just hard to see from the
outside until there's some sort of you
know intervention from the government
and when I say intervention you know it
could be just kind of like talking more
straightforwardly about what their plans
are acknowledging that there is an issue
that needs to be addressed and it can be
addressed either through clarification
or whether it's change of plan
um but it's just hard to see in without
any kind of intervention that this
doesn't just continue like this but it
is the key thing Jane here is that what
are we talking about right now we're
trapped in something that I don't know
is it a kind of markets crisis a
financial requirement that's probably
you know if the bank of England's
intervening in markets maybe that makes
it a financial crisis but there's a
difference between things happening in
markets and this transmission mechanism
that means eventually households have to
pay it and right now it feels like we're
kind of in the eye of the storm of that
markets moment
it's only you know in the coming months
that it really starts to be real for
many households and to some extent it's
already happening because if you're
trying to get a mortgage right now it's
kind of difficult but that's the thing
to watch and the sooner this markets
crisis gets dealt with the less we have
to worry about that other stuff further
down the line yeah we've had some good
examples of real world impacts of this
actually this morning I mean we've had a
trading statement from next which is
regarded as the best retail business in
the UK on the UK stock market by none
they've actually guided the market that
they're going to be making 20 million
bats less profit this year and that is
because they have detected concerns in
consumer sentiment August was not as
good a month as they were expecting it
to be and they've also said by the way
um while that the inflationary picture
in terms of close price inflation is
that Simon Watson the chief executive as
I say it's a is a retail Sage he's
actually said today we're seeing lower
prices at the factory but because we all
of those prices are denominated in US
Dollars UK customers are I'm not going
to get the benefit from it that's just
one example of the sort of real world
consequences of this
like is it possible you know looking at
your
crew were sort of Out of the Woods of
all of this uncertainty I don't I don't
think there is at the moment I mean it's
probably a better place to ask that
question I'll answer that question but
the reality is is that all we can do at
the moment is take things day by day the
bank of England intervened yesterday had
the you know its intervention had the
desired effects of of stabilizing and
calming markets but as we've talked
about that intervention is due to last
just for a couple of weeks the question
comes at the end of that are the Pension
funds that effectively Force the bank to
intervene yesterday are they in a
Sounder financial position uh talking to
some people in that market today
actually they're very concerned because
we're at the end of September now at the
end of the quarter of the third quarter
of the Year many of them face demands
around this point to renegotiate or
renew their foreign exchange Hedges of
course what's happened to Sterling in
recent days is going to put pressure on
them in that respect so they are very
nervous still about what the future the
immediate future holds and so trying to
put a time frame on a fast-moving
volatile situation like this that spans
financial markets
um I think is invidious